foreign
[Music]
store is live from the Sky News City
Studio
Sainsbury's joins the chorus of
supermarkets saying food inflation is
starting to fall as first quarter sales
grow
ing mortgage rates break the six percent
Mark for the first time since last
October's mini budget
and a record tune for Ryanair as
passenger numbers hit 17.4 million
[Music]
good morning this is business life with
Ian King at the new times of 11 30 and 4
30 every weekday here on Sky News well
Sainsbury's this morning became the
latest supermarket chain to report that
it's seeing food price inflation
starting to fall Simon Roberts chief
executive of the UK's second largest
grocery retailer said the company was
fully committed to passing on savings to
its customers and since March had spent
60 million pounds on cutting the price
of essential lines like bread butter
milk pasta chicken and toilet roll all
the comments came as Sainsbury's
reported that during the 16 weeks to the
24th of June it says we're at 9.2
percent on the same period a year ago
excluding fuel
for joining me now is Sue radishev he's
the news redditor at retail week Hugh
good to see you this morning I mean I
noticed that sales growth During the
period was actually way below where food
and drink price inflation was so the
implication is that Sainsbury's have had
to absorb some of those costs and taken
a hit to its margin
yeah definitely and I
that's right I was on a call with with
Simon
and I think he was very keen to kind of
make that point that you know
Sainsbury's while some prices have been
going up have been inflating behind the
market and that stages has been
investing very heavily in in keeping
those prices down where they can and
cushioning those sort of input costs for
customers where it's not being you know
possible to to cut prices
what's interesting though is that while
they're saying uh decline in food price
inflation they're still seeing elevated
labor costs I mean that's another Point
Simon Roberts has been making today
yeah and I think that's something that
the supermarkets and and customers are
going to have to I guess learn to live
with I mean we've seen price I I think
Sainsbury's has increased wages three
times in the last 18 months and you know
rightly so for for Supermarket uh stuff
but that is obviously gonna have a
knock-on effect to to some prices
and I think you know coming back to a
perception point of view this is
something that maybe the supermarkets
need to explain to to customers that
this may lead to some stubbornly higher
prices sort of moving into the future
absolutely I mean obviously uh the
supermarkets were wrapped Yesterday by
the competition and markets Authority
for uh expanding their margins on fuel
prices I mean Asda and Morrisons caught
most of the Flack but what did Mr
Roberts have to say on that this morning
uh as you say I mean I think Asda and
Morrisons I mean Asda was fined and
Morrison sort of named uh as increasing
margins on the fuel uh Simon Roberts was
I wouldn't say it was apologetic I think
he was quite open in saying that
Sainsbury's doesn't have any margins on
fuel and that sort of any benefit I
think was the word he called uh you know
margin excess profit on fuel was going
back into investing in fuel to to keep
prices down having said that he wasn't
particularly Keen to to actually say
what the increased margin year on year
on fuel price actually worked
but I think very it's very interesting
here at the moment about the sector is
that obviously you've seen Tesco
introduce this dual pricing I.E Club
Card members getting discounts that
ordinary Shoppers don't and Sainsbury's
are now doing the same with nectar
yeah exactly and I think you know from a
purely business point of view it's it's
you know the right move I mean customers
are a desperate for lower prices and
I've clearly been shopping down and you
know the risk from the Discounters is
always looming
I think given now that we're in a
slightly different place where almost
profit is bad for supermarkets and and
businesses shouldn't be seen to be
profiteering it's made me an ethical
question there around whether it's right
to be putting such huge discounts behind
you know things that customers have to
sign up to do and share their data but I
guess from a fundamental business point
of view is that's good practice yeah
it's a good way building loyalty isn't
it I guess and what about uh what about
Argos I mean it's easy to forget uh
Sainsbury's owns Argos as well I mean
that looks to be trading reasonably well
in in again quite a tough environment
yeah exactly and I think you know we've
been critical in the past certainly
retweek and others and since Simon
Roberts has come in with his food first
strategy of maybe not uh putting enough
behind Argos uh they've obviously made
some huge changes spend a lot of money
bringing some Standalone Argos stores
into Sainsbury's supermarkets and as you
say clearly based on the trading figures
I think it was up over four percent uh
it seems to be working you know people
obviously going in for their big shop
with the food and they might pick
something up click and collect or you
know even use one of the kiosks there to
sort of make a purchase while they're
there so it does seem that that you know
that his um his strategy around Argos is
is certainly bearing fruit yeah the
share price is off this morning with
some investors potentially looking for
an earnings upgrade this morning
well they may well have been but I think
it would be given the political
situation and obviously as we've touched
on the select committee last week the
CMA report yesterday you know if there
have been a profits upgrades today as
you buy or given out by Sainsbury's
in this slightly Strange World we're
living in now that actually I think that
would only have caused more problems for
for Sainsbury's and more questions to
face around you know profiteering and
and whether they're unfairly raising
prices not just on fuel but also on on
food
yeah she say you it is a strange world
right now good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and Ryanair said this morning it
flew more passengers in June than in any
month in its history Europe's biggest
Airline carried 17.4 million passengers
in June that was up nine percent on the
same month last year well the previous
record of 17 million was set in May the
carrier said it operated more than 96
250 flights during the month although
more than 900 flights were canceled due
mainly to air traffic control strikes
Ryanair said those disputes affected
around 160 000 passengers
Facebook's owner meta platforms is
launching a new Social and micro
blogging app to rival Twitter threads
which will be linked to Instagram will
go live on Thursday and is already
available for pre-order on the Apple App
Store well the news comes days after
Twitter's owner Elon Musk announced that
every user will have a limit on the
number of tweets that they can see each
day effectively looking out many regular
and heavy uses of the platform
and the uk-based electric van maker
arrival has scrapped a proposed merger
with a so-called blank check company
that would have boosted its cash
reserves arrival which is listed on the
U.S Nasdaq exchange and as plans to
merge with Kensington Capital
acquisition core five in April we're in
a move that would have given it access
to 283 million dollars worth of cash no
reason was given for the decision but
arrival which said recently it would run
out of cash by the end of the year said
it would now pursue alternative Avenues
to provide it with additional liquidity
and the average five-year fixed-rate
Residential Mortgage has broken the six
percent Mark for the first time since
the mini budget last October hitting
6.01 that's up from 5.97 yesterday or
while the average two-year fixed
mortgage is now at 6.47 also up slightly
on yesterday those figures come of
course after the financial conduct
Authority some of the chief Executives
of Britain's major Banks to a meeting on
Thursday amid accusations that they may
be profiteering from rising interest
rates
foreign
streets were followed by a mixed session
overnight for equities in the
asia-pacific region that's the current
picture of course Hong Kong and Shanghai
finished uh slightly higher in mid hopes
of more stimulus measures from Beijing
the Nick a bit of profit taking creeping
in there after Monday's performance in
Europe stocks all in negative territory
this morning on the major indices
treading a little bit muted today
there's no lead later on from Wall
Street which is closed for the 4th of
July bank holiday talking points again
include Casino the French supermarket
chain is there by 16 this morning that's
on news it has two offers on the table
from billionaire investors prepared to
back a refinancing the latest one of
which comes from the Czech investor
Daniel kratinski he of course is a major
shareholder in the UK in Sainsbury's in
Romeo and of course West Ham United
we're here in London the ftse 100 is in
positive territory right now up a sixth
of one percent nearly much of that is
being driven by a rally in shares of
AstraZeneca following yesterday's
sell-off you remember we were talking
about other than the 4 30 show yesterday
afternoon uh well AstraZeneca is up two
and a half percent this morning that's
been enough to put nearly 20 points on
the ftse on its own on the downside well
Sainsbury's mentioned just been talking
about them off nearly one and three
quarter percent on that trading update
outside the foot Sea the retailer dunelm
is off by nearly five percent that's on
adverse broker comment but wizer has
rallied by one and a half percent on the
Ryanair traffic figures well the foreign
exchange markets well again it's pretty
quiet with the US closed today Sterling
up for nearly tenth of one percent
against the door it's up by nearly
quarter one percent against the Euro The
single currency meanwhile off a tenth of
one percent against the Greenback
for the oil price well that's rallied
today following the extension to
production Cuts announced by the Saudi
Arabians and the Russians yesterday
Baron Brent crude will currently set you
back 75 58 cents a barrel that is up one
and a quarter percent on the session
joining me to discuss all that is Dr
Jimmy mashateri senior Equity Analyst at
investec well Jimmy good to see you this
morning I mean AstraZeneca got to talk
about it again massive sell-off
yesterday now we were a guest at 4 30 in
the very spot you where you are said he
thought the sell-off was rational uh
what do you think about this rally that
we've had today yeah indeed I think um
guy was right yesterday that that's what
the market was pricing in it was
effectively saying that the results were
not to the standard that the market
hoped for and therefore they were
writing down the probability of the drug
succeeding however I think as investors
this is where we get an opportunity to
go against the market and actually say
that this particular drug in lung cancer
is not dead and buried in fact it
actually met one of the core primary
endpoints and so they still hope out
there and because of that when the full
results come out particularly on the
overall survival core primary endpoint
which is effectively means that the drug
helps people to live longer
um then you know we could see this uh
doing very very well I mean this is a
really exciting time in healthcare Jim
isn't it I mean obviously AZ have made
great strides in oncology
um there's a big piece in the Ft today
about some of the things that are going
on in the neuroscience and and
Alzheimer's base and generally we've had
lots of really quite positive updates
from the likes of Novartis and GSK
lately 100 this has been the conference
season where a lot of this
pharmaceutical and healthcare companies
have been on the road
um displaying their words as it were for
for investors and we have had many very
positive results one of the most talked
about has been the Obesity drugs in
particularly Eli Lilly and Novo Nordisk
continue to shine there you've mentioned
novices which had a fantastic result in
in breast cancer and also GSK and Pfizer
and the results in adult respiratory
Synthesia virus which is a winter virus
that kills many many vulnerable people
so even though it's very good for the
pharmaceutical companies it's huge
strides for people in terms of health
and improving well-being more broadly
Jimmy we're on the cusp of Q2 earnings
season one of people like you looking
out for indeed I think the starting
point is that the market continues to
think that in earnings are inflated at
this point and continue to pricing
Innings downgrades as you go through the
year so the Q2 ending season is going to
be very very important what we have
heard from the conference season thus
far is is that most of the companies
actually don't see a negative outlook
and so what to expect is that growth is
going to remain fairly steady margins
are going to remain resilient and so we
don't expect to see that much in the way
of Innings downgrades if that turns out
to be right and we don't see Market
consensus moving down on earnings what
we expect is that the markets will
remain very supportive all the way
perhaps through to the end of the year
all right Jimmy always good to see you
thanks for coming on this morning
fantastic thank you very much
now changing technology regulation and
customer expectations mean it's more
important than ever for businesses to
react more rapidly to changes but
preferably without overworking their
employees well that's put a greater
emphasis on so-called management process
automation using software to automate
repetitive tasks and functions such as
project workflow and document management
one of the leading players in the field
is active Ops whose clients include
Allied Irish Banks and Nationwide
building society today it announced
underlying earnings of seven hundred
thousand pounds for the year to the end
of March compared with a loss of 300 000
pounds during the previous 12 months but
joining me now is Richard Jeffrey chief
executive of active Ops Richard good to
see you this morning I mean on the face
of it to me it looks like you're getting
existing customers to spend more with
you rather than getting in new customers
or am I over simplifying things greatly
well the world of works not getting any
easier right in the actual challenges of
just managing the complexity which we
all hear in the newspapers around hybrid
working means our customers are if you
like needing more decision intelligence
which about where people are and what
they've got to do
what services are you seeing the
greatest demand for right now
I think particularly in the areas which
traditionally have a lot of expertise in
them where they rely on a very capable
people but also they have Peaks and
demands you know pigs and troughs in
demand which make them quite difficult
to run
um so there's a lot of Need for better
better if you like visibility and work
better access to capability the ability
to leverage your your skills based in
different Pockets when they're not in
the same room as you anymore that's
quite a hard problem so that's area
another big area of concern is is around
the the overhead around operational risk
and compliance you know money laundering
regulations require Banks and and
financial services to do so much more in
that area so again having a good tight
oversight but also visibility to
Regulators is really really important
and to what extent do you incorporating
Ai and machine learning into what you do
well we I mean there's clearly so much
attention to that moment and the impact
on AI in processing generally I think is
going to be huge but our particular
spinner around that is if you like the
the control over those things I mean
history shows us time and time again
it's not the technology that you know
the ability to have technology it's the
ability to exploit them that is the
differentiator so we're really focusing
with our customers on embedding the the
AI in our platform so that you as a
consumer or a customer you know you get
the benefit of being able to control the
other tools and the Technologies your
your organization uses I mean for
example when when Once Upon a Time you
know managing and tracking the skills of
your people is a very manual and
difficult process and largely constru
you know carried in people's heads our
technology with the with the data
platform we have and the underlying
sense of you know the inter the
knowledge of how to do this stuff well
our software can now all do all that for
you so you know and have it at your
fingertips the sort of skills
information that's a massive impact not
just on you as an individual but on your
organization if you've got a big back
office of 10 000 people you know that
that makes us big saving a big impact on
your performance
are you having to spend more on R D as a
result of all this innovation
in our particular case we've had a
fairly high focus on R D for many years
but it's it's steady I mean our our
issue in many cases is the capacity to
exploit and consume our product so so we
are able to bring new Tooling in
oh dear we appear to have uh lost uh
Richard Jeffrey there from active oops
that's rather shame I was enjoying that
conversation I should tell you by the
way that uh his share price is up some
six percent sir right now he's back
Richard sorry do we lost you momentarily
there um Before I Let You Go um
obviously you're very very uh sort of
geared your customer base towards
Banking and Financial Services do you
see that changing over time
well the problem is a generic one it
just applies as much to public sector
and back offices that support us in the
passport agency and the dvla you know
the problems of managing work and
capacity is so generic Ian so so in our
particular case because there's a very
clear Market we're you know we're we
have a huge Target Market within our
domain absolutely we're staying focused
there but the opportunity I think to
make an impact as the kind of tools
we're talking about get deployed in all
sorts of environments the need for
control and I don't mean screaming I
mean actually being into controller on
top of is only growing greater so
there's this huge applicability of this
this type of uh software across the
world fascinating hope to hear more from
it uh from you in future Richard good to
see you today thank you likewise thank
you
still to come here on business life how
Finance is still making its way to
Growing businesses don't go away
[Music]
play Sky News
from the Sky News Center at seven now
that you're up to date we can go into a
bit more detail things can change
incredibly quickly taken by surprise
have you ever known A Moment Like This
in British politics before yes cheers
we'll start with breaking news let's get
the latest on the ground so by the end
we'll hopefully all understand what's
going on in the world just not looking
better
[Music]
I'm David Blevins and I'm Skye's senior
Ireland correspondent
I'm based in Belfast a city transformed
by Pace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
Northern Ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
Generations
it takes 60 Minutes to cross the Irish
sea it took the British Monarchy
essentially
spent 25 years reporting the journey
from conflict to peace
the political parties of Northern
Ireland have reached agreement
understand the world with us
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in Parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to Winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
Far East in the Atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Fly Emirates fly better
welcome back I just want to bring you a
bit of breaking news that sir just
reached us which is that Thames water
has been fined 3.3 million pounds in
court that is after it pleaded guilty to
four charges relating to polluting
rivers near Gatwick Airport in 2017 more
on that throughout the morning as we get
it here
and while the banks are Under Fire from
politicians over the issue of savings
rates the treasury select committee is
also currently investigating the issues
faced by small and medium-sized
Enterprises in accessing financing yet
Finance is still making its way too smes
the alternative Finance provider thin
cats this morning reported it loaned a
record 191 million pounds to smes during
the first six months of the year that
was up 45 on the first six months of
last year with me now it's the managing
director of think at Ravi and Aunt Ravi
good to see you again this morning um
what sectors are most in need of Finance
right now so we're seeing a lot of
demand from B2B service businesses good
recurring revenues good profit margins
that aren't totally isolated from
inflationary impact but somewhat
um and there's a lot of m a a lot of
growth so we're funding scale up and
growth and that's where the demand is
for those sorts of businesses and what's
the typical duration of a loan between
four and five years
um with
um some element of amortization Summit
so 53 50 ammo and bullet so when you
take account of interest rates and
amortization these are a good cash flow
generative businesses able to repay
those loans and services they're debt
and what about the rates you're charging
so we're charging a floating rate um six
plus
um reflecting the fact that we're
lending to businesses that generally
don't have hard assets yeah and that's
quite different to where most banks and
either non-bank lenders are yeah you can
I mean there's there's not much security
that you can take in a lot of cases the
security is the business so we're
backing entrepreneurs we're backing
growth businesses where um the value or
the the asset is the business and and so
we spend a lot of time with management
understanding their businesses we
recently for example to Stephen
Bartlett's uh PR business uh flight
Story made two Acquisitions
um and we got into depth with him and
his team around what those Acquisitions
mean for that business and what means
for their profits now I think on the
figures that you put out today means
that you've learned something learned
something like 1.4 billion pounds to
date what kind of delinquency rates do
you see it's very low
um and we've been going since 2017 our
um default rate is um sub one percent
um and to be honest it's exceptionally
benign across all markets at the moment
there was going to be no doubt to pick
up in delinquencies clearly I don't
think that from my book but uh um you
know we do remain in benign environment
for Consumer real estate clearly's got
immediate impact but I think SME at the
micro end particularly not where we lend
we learn to bigger businesses is going
to hit some buffers very very soon
obviously yeah I mean that's pretty
spectacular such a low delinquency rate
given that it is quite a high risk
profile to which you're lending I mean
do you look at every single loan
application or is there a chunk of it
that's automated no there's no there's
an element Automation in that we we
filter learns through our credit model
that we have but we meet the
entrepreneurs we meet the borrowers we
we pull apart their financials and and
question what they're doing so it is
traditional banking perhaps Ally with
some data oversight and some Data
Insights what do you do you think you're
taking share from some of the
established lenders yes we are beginning
to see that I mean it does take time
because the incumbents own the clients
as such so we originate our loans
through advisors around the country
we're very Regional more than half of
what we did as outside of the outside of
London
um and so these Regional advisors
meet the entrepreneurs and package up
ideas which they showed to us but not
all borrowers will leave a bank and
that's the challenge how do the banks be
encouraged to show the market things
that they won't fund and in a word is
you're going to see this sort of growth
for the remainder of this year yeah
our pipeline remains very strong we
think um a modest decrease in Bank
appetite which we're beginning to see
will be beneficial for us and clearly as
our name grows more advisors know us and
we do a lot of follow-on a lot of buy
and build so more than half of we expect
is just that follow-on from that from
those businesses that we fund already
very good Ravi great to catch up with
you this morning thanks for joining me
that's it for me I'm back at 4 30 this
afternoon hope very much to see you then
in the meantime do stay tuned after this
short break it's Jane secker thanks for
joining me cheerio
that's great
[Music]
foreign